ben a tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
video deciso di farlo con lo sfondo mio
solito perché tra poco scomparire nel
senso che stiamo per fare una cosa
incredibile che non vi spoiler ma questo
bellissimo sfondo c'è la tappa un po
schivo qualcuno mette voi che scriverò
questo fondo qua cambierà totalmente non
avete idea era di 6 a 9 che l'altra
volta ho eguagliato il mio record in una
maniera che non mi sono anche spiegare
io ho fatto 31 31 la scorsa volta
proprio adesso il terzo episodio
spero di fare più di 31 di record mamma
mia incredibile ogni volta il guaio il
mio record di mortacci mia almeno 32
questo l'obiettivo va beh largo allora
classic perché l'altra modalità è un
casino tra facepalm e the white al match
gli elmetti piano penso che facepalm
facepalm sia il più cercato perfetto
sono saremmo partiti così anche noi fin
qua pisa di più perché tutti cianni mon
e in questo mondo sarà predict 4 milioni
[Musica]
caracas e c'azzecca o meglio ad andare
in soldi proprio tra pisa e a rampe un
mio dio a rampe non credo che lo sta
cercando più qualcuno meno
i dati sono aggiornati all'inizio 2018 è
quindi teoricamente devo tornare
indietro con il con la mente ai tempi
del serial meno
non ho idea di cosa sia ma va bene ok
giorno di san valentino di più dai podi
innamorati nel mondo perfetto grazie
viva l'amore
fate figli chris evans mamma mia penso
che tutti quanti abbiano cercato
valentine's day dopo dopo chris evans
per tentare di marchiarsi secondo me
di più mio dio chris evans non potevi
essere più figo ancora sporco demonio
sforzo la partenza ragazzi e per i bimbi
come diciamo sempre il riscaldamento
anche lui né da cotanto risultato lager
lower sul petto come fai a stato abbiano
notato solo adesso è come se vi scrive
si qua è più il fatto destra quindi il
magari sto zitto che deve australian
open e stay lowder non l'ho mai neanche
sentito non so cosa sia meno
mamma mia meno male sica vyrus meno
immagino mamma mia alla musica con
l'artista l'africa non è fidanzata in
sicilia non esita a quello no perché ci
avrebbe senso il virus della fidanzata
che ti porta fa shopping un casinò si
collegava anche al negozio di prima di
creare e clyde priming di più immagino
anche se poco cercato almeno di più su
juan manuel santos fino a mi chiedeva
quando sarebbe spuntato irreprensibile
joan manuel santos non sapevo facesse
anche economia meno infatti meno male
grande juan manuel santos sarai meno dei
beatles penso di sì dai beatles with 2
milioni ci dimettiamo solo veramente i
beatles o open però pope censurate
perché non poteva mettere quella giusta
non esagerato col nuovo un gelato
comunque qualcosa di sopra quindi coppe
allora considerando che il web è pieno
di maschietti in considerando che
633mila ricerche al mese le faccio solo
io non lo so meno meno ma tommaso
rischiato laga meno male cercato meno
perché pensando a uno se cerca po specie
perché proprio la parola quella proprio
cruda no quella che inizia con la teen
telefono quindi se non cerchi quello non
ha senso che tu scriva tema beh dai neo
avanti o epatite epatite meno uguale le
proprie l'epatite c ha la stessa fame
incredibile e faty the rat sheeran
beh certo sono entrambi degli ottimi un
paragone incredibile
butch iran secondo me quei 5 milioni 66
va bene come cristiano ronaldo e cina
mamma mia wikipedia wikipedia wiki piedi
non so come si dice prof
credo che abbia più ricerche white
bibbia wikipedia tipo di spini 9 27 27
sapere importanti 13 milioni va bene mi
sono cagato sotto va bene citizen kane
[Musica]
meno ragazzi siamo a 11
perché il record non è per tutti e solo
per i migliori e io lo fui come fossero
gli youtuber senza record prossimamente
matfield ma di tipo a prescindere la
forza non so cosa sia billy john che non
è billy gioco dei green day che pensate
voi
l'altro è molto più senza capelli anche
noi sembra il mio vecchio propri mondi
musica c'entra niente questo lo tagliamo
no non lo tagliamo da meno dai primi
giorni avrà poi 74.000 mazza bravo
bigioni giorno mike tyson penso che mike
tyson almeno 450 ce li abbia quindi
siamo sul milioncino mike va bene mike
non importa tra mike tyson e pensione
che penso che pensione si è cercato solo
dagli italiani così tanto pensione
almeno mezzo milione ce l'hanno però non
supera mike tyson
dovete line cazzotti in faccia sono
meglio da pensione perfetto con sti
ragionamenti ci arrivo siamo a metà
record pensione o ciclo ciclo di più
fantastico a metà siamo arrivati 16 che
la metà di meno del più della metà di 31
tutta la strada che ho fatale so devo
fare di nuovo se riesco battuto il
reciclo e narcos
penso che narcos si astra cercato
mammamia milione e mezzo va bene
giampiero mettimi nella nella nella
schermata sinistra proprio tutta
sinistra metti minimo o che ci sono ok
per fermo sei fermo lì è arrivato un
subscriber grazie torniamo seri ce l'ho
fatta più o meno sembravo credo di
esserci riuscito fate uno screen yasser
apparat arafat
e la mia faccia quando le ragazze mi
dicono ma noi c'è solo amicizia tra di
noi guarda che faccia meno signora di
essere un po meno
ecco gli asset o idraulico di più i tubi
sono sempre ricercati degli arabi bill
russell
allora io non seguo tanto basta
ma spero che il russell sia un po meno
cercato degli idraulici se non vali
aggiustato i tubi perfetto
siamo a venti ragazzo è un buon record
ping di più non lo usa nessuno ama di
più sicuro mammamia bing bravissimo
undertaker cosa mi state mettendo andate
chi ha di meno ed avrà poi trash no 600
mila 400 riguardo ma tu questo è
difficile meno ti prego meno ti prego
meno li mortacci tua ci riprova dai
nostro tentativo ci un altro tentativo
pagano allora dio o banana cake torta la
banana che penso siano due cose molto
relative nel senso che tu va in chiesa
preghi dio e poi vai a casa c'è la torta
le banane
quindi penso siano più o meno league ma
la torta le banane avrà 74.000 non di
più mamma mia se ci attestiamo è stata
la trinité torta le banane o hank aaron
facciamo meno meno bravo in caro hank
aaron o lebron
vabbè lebron quei 6 milioni 5 e mezzo 5
mezzo 3 mamma mia va bene le trono
marathon ecco mareco anka céline
paragona mandava due milioni devono fare
di più
mammamia meno male maradona si giocava
maradona e perdita di peso o perdita di
peso potrebbe essere stata cercata però
maradona mi sta comportanto ma che non
sia 450 va bene va bene
nadal il raffa sicuramente di più natale
sarà cui sui due milioni e mezzo
milione e mezzo pensavo di sì va bene va
bene va bene data la wonder woman di
meno [ __ ] maledetti ma secondo me
tutte quelle chiuse da fatte solo giulia
penna quando si è vestita da wonder
woman momenti di vero godimento questi
grazie giulia ma quando un boccale
grazie giulia senza contesto vedere
grazie giulia nottingham forest os
easing che in meno partiamo da dio
31 mancano solo 30 per arrivare al
record ci siamo ragazzi siamo lì a bonn
di più cristo redentore di meno vulcano
vulcano surfing puoi fare i sette sul
vulcano non meno ma non dica che nessun
e serve sul vulcano anche perché lo
vedrai un po come un azzardata star come
prova bello mozart eno dai 400mila va
bene anche così nintendo wii magra
nintendo wii non sia più così tanto
cercato perché cercano in tempo più o
meno infatti ormai dal 2006 vecchi tempi
tyler noti l'air cosa diavolo è meno
non sto capendo neanche cosa sia html di
più quei 5 milioni ce li ha il migliore
va bene ben affleck
secondo meno di un milione saiwa fango
la storia l'ultimo masai mara o nascita
nascita di più perfetto partiamo da dio
allora questa è veramente l'ultimo gerry
scotti di meno ragazzi però che questo
video vi sia piaciuto non c'è verso
oggi faccio schifo ragazzi oggi faccio
schifo far mi sono impegnato sono stato
molto molto sincero si è impegnato è
stata una dura battaglia qualcosa
abbiamo portato a casa lo spero mamma
mia ragazzi sono veramente impegnato
oggi non c'era verso 22
immortali di via controbatte rosso
record ragazzi spero che questo mi ha
risposto giulia penna sentiamo risposta
no capito sapessi giulietta sapere però
che vi sia piaciuto di schede che ha
schiacciato la bellissima campanellina
su cosa che ti vct che vedevamo
notifiche quando metto i nuovi video noi
ci vediamo
signore e signori come sempre a un
prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]